at one of the lead authors of this
research how disappointed are you buy it
so good evening to you clearly uh any
negative result is a disappointment but
unfortunately to some extent
it was predictable because studies over
the past few weeks have clearly
indicated that even past infection with
the original virus that was circulating
in south africa was not conferring
protection against
reinfection due to the variant but i
think importantly to emphasize is that
this speaks to mild
infection and based on the estrogenic
vaccine and a jnj vaccine
using a very similar sort of technology
in terms of its development
as well as the immune responses being
comparable
the jnj vaccine in south africa against
the variant has been shown
to reduce moderate to severe disease by
57
and severe disease by as much as 89
so i think there might still well be a
role for estrogenic vaccine
at least in terms of protecting against
severe disease
but unfortunately not so for mild
moderate infection
due to the variant of circulating in
south africa and that has really
dispersed into many other countries as
well
of course you know we're watching with
interest because we do have now
cases of the south african variant here
in the uk which we're
trying to surge test for and stamp out
but of course the implications for you
in south africa
are much more profound not least because
if you do have to move to the j and j
the yanson vaccine that will have
potentially
what cost implications as well uh it
certainly would uh because the planning
was around the estrogenic vaccine has
been the main source of vaccine that
south africa would procure
so it would have cost implications but i
think also in the uk
uh it's not about keeping the borders
shut and avoiding the
emergence of these sort of vietnamese
even the kent
variant in the uk is in it the variant
that was
originated in kent as an example has
already started to mutate and start
to develop mutations that include
critical components
that are part of the mutation of the
variant that was first identified in
south africa
so i think this is going to be a natural
evolution of the virus
and not just one the way these variants
are imported into another country
but rather the evolution of the virus
when faced
with immune pressure that's induced by
natural infection or even vaccine
injuries
so can i infer from that that you're
opposed to the border being shut between
the uk and south africa
it's going to survive to purpose i think
you're going to see it in fact the virus
has already
disseminated into many countries and to
believe that you're going to be able to
control the spread of the virus by
keeping the border shut the question
also is how long
are you going to keep your borders shut
these variants are not going to
disappear from south africa
they're going to continue circulating
throughout africa and they've already
probably spread to many of the
neighboring countries
with a huge amount of traffic that takes
place between south africa or not so it
will probably be a need for the world to
shut its borders
not just to south africa and africa but
also to brazil because
the variant is currently circulating in
manaus in in brazil which is equally
worrisome
as the south african variant so i think
there needs to be a recalibration
in terms of how we think about the
covert 19 pandemic and the role that
vaccines are going to play moving
forward
okay very interesting just going back to
your research in terms of the
astrozenica vaccine
i know that there hasn't been much
research into
its efficacy in serious cases it's
thought
that there is some confidence that it
would still work in terms of the south
african variant is that your belief
i do believe so so i believe that tsl
immunity probably plays a more important
role
in terms of protecting against severe
disease i think antibodies are important
especially for upper respiratory
illnesses and that is the mild spectrum
of disease
but when it comes to severe disease it's
difficult to explain the jensen results
without it being because of something
else other than antibody because like i
mentioned the antibody responses
between estrogenic vaccine and jensen
and jensen vaccine are in fact
almost identical so it is something else
that's working in terms of protecting
against severe disease
and all indications are that the t cell
responses
that are induced by the vaccine are less
affected
in terms of dividers being able to evade
that particular response meanwhile in
the uk this week there's been discussion
about well in fact there's been a new
trial
launched into the mixing of vaccines
perhaps a different dose for the second
to the first of course a lot of people
be disappointed by by
the results of your study but there is
reason to be hopeful
about new emerging approaches to this
disease isn't there
uh most certainly uh and i don't think
this is the end of the game
i mean i think we were somewhat euphoric
from the first initial results that
were being reported of 25 efficacy but
we experiencing circulation of a very
different virus now
and at the end of the day it's not that
vaccines are going to eradicate
the virus in the near future not even in
the distant future
uh it's about how we want him to
prioritize things and from our own
perspective it's
about saving lives it's about preventing
hospitalizations and i think even the
current generation of vaccines have got
a huge role to play
uh be it a susana vaccine or be a
combination of other vaccines
uh they have got a huge role to play in
terms of get having an immediate impact
on saving lives of people and the
challenge still remains the rollout of
these vaccines
and equity of distribution globally um
we're having a few problems with the
line but i want to persevere given
the relevance of you to this story and i
just want to ask you finally
um about the question of vaccine
distribution they've been
well questioned serious questions being
raised from around the world about the
hoarding
by western nations particularly south
africans president has spoken out about
this is it your view
that perhaps once the uk has started
immunising everyone over 50 that they
should be
donating their vaccines to you guys in
south africa
well it's not only the uk it's also
countries such as canada that have
subscribed to more than five times
what's required for their population
uh and i think those sort of initiatives
should be started immediately and not uh
after they've got 100
coverage in that specific populations
because i think
what we're facing right now is everyone
appreciates it's a global emergency
and the more that we are the less people
that are vaccinated the more infections
that take place in countries such as
south africa and other countries
the greater the likelihood that there's
going to be evolution of other variants
that are even going to become more
resistant to the naturally induced
immune
immunity so what we're going to be
facing is continuous evolution of the
virus
with further variants that are going to
become available those are going to
eventually spread
into the high income countries who are
essentially using first generation
vaccines
and then you're going to start seeing
outbreaks because of these variants
which we haven't been able to control
outside of high-income countries because
of lack of access
in those other countries to cover 19
vaccines